[tapping on glass]
- WAS I SPEEDING, OFFICER?
- YOU DON'T LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE FROM AROUND HERE.
- NO, SIR.
- YOU BEEN DOING
ANY DRUGS TONIGHT?
- NO, SIR.
- NOPE?
- NO.
- WHY DON'T YOU
POP THAT TRUNK,
STEP OUT OF THE VEHICLE
FOR ME, PLEASE.
- REALLY?
- YEAH.
[trunk pops]
- [sighs]
[seatbelt clicks]
- NO DRUGS, HUH?
- NOPE.
[indistinct radio chatter]
- WELL, WELL, WELL.
[trunk closes]
WHAT HAVE WE HERE?
- NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
YOU PLANTED THAT IN MY CAR.
- OH, DID I?
OR...DID I PLANT THIS?
- UH--I REAL--I GUESS--
- UP AGAINST THE CAR,
RIGHT NOW.
- OH!
- SPREAD 'EM!
- UH--
- HUH, WHAT'S GOING--
WHOA, WHOA.
WHAT DO WE HAVE HERE, HUH?
- WHAT?
- THESE YOUR COLORS, HOMIE?
- THAT'S--THAT'S NOT MINE.
- HUH?
- NO, I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT--
- WHAT? NO?
OR ARE THESE YOUR COLORS?
OR PERHAPS THESE
ARE YOUR COLORS.
OR ARE THESE--?
LOOK AT ALL THESE COLORS.
MAN, YOU SURE GOT
A LOT OF COLORS.
- I DON'T--
- LOOK AT ALL OF THESE COLORS.
- WHAT, THIS IS--
- WASAH!
- ARE YOU A REAL COP?
- FREEZE!
WHAT IS THAT?
- WHAT--
- MM.
WELL, WELL, WELL.
IT LOOKS LIKE
AN ILLEGAL FIREARM.
OR...
IS IT? AHH.
[dove cooing]
- OH.
I'M--I DON'T--
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS IS.
I'M SORRY.
- PICK A CARD.
- THAT'S NOT EVEN A GOOD FAN.
- ANY CARD.
YOU CAN JUST STICK--THERE.
OKAY, YOU TOOK THAT CARD?
- YEAH.
- NOW, CAN YOU
REMEMBER THAT CARD?
- YES.
- CAN YOU COMMIT THAT CARD
TO MEMORY?
- THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
- HAVE YOU DONE SO?
HAVE YOU DONE SO?
- YES.
- PLEASE INSERT THE CARD BACK
INTO THE DECK RANDOMLY.
- DONE.
- IT'S IN A DIFFERENT PLACE THAN
WHERE YOU TOOK IT ORIGINALLY?
- THERE.
- THERE WE ARE. THERE WE ARE.
- THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
- NOW, I TAKE THE DECK LIKE SO.
I GIVE IT A "SKASLOISLES"
AND "ABRACASLOISH."
[gunshot]
- UH, FU--WHA--
- OKAY...
AHH.
IS THIS YOUR CARD?
- NO!
- ARE YOU SURE?
- I WANT YOUR BADGE NUMBER.
[coughing]
- OH. OH. OH!
- [coughing]
UH--UH--WHA--
WHAT DID--
OH!
- HAAH.
- HOW DID--
IT'S MY CA--
HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
- AHH.
AND...
THAT IS FOR YOU.
- AFTER ALL THAT,
YOU'RE STILL GIVING ME A TICKET?
- IS IT A TICKET?
OR IS IT A TWO-FOR-ONE COUPON
FOR MY SHOW
AT THE MAGIC HOUSE
THURSDAY NIGHT AT 11:00 P.M.?
YOUR CALL.
- I'LL TAKE THE TICKET.
- GREAT. OKAY.